[Música]
cubre 17 millones de hectáreas en
Francia cerca de un tercio del
territorio
el bosque una riqueza para nuestro
ecosistema
también un recurso cada año 38 millones
de Tres metros cúbicos de madera son
transformados en material Industrial
madera de construcción o madera para
calefacción en senaf uno de los bosques
más grandes de la isla de Francia los
equipos de la oficina Nacional de los
bosques velan para hacer fructificar ese
oro verde para este roble El veredicto
es implacable
su tasa de Rama fina es mucho más
inferior que la de la izquierda Entonces
vamos a quitar este ellos permitirá
Igualmente darle un poco más de espacio
al de la izquierda que podrá
desarrollarse tiene un diámetro de 65
centímetros una marca roja que le
indicará al leñador que hay que tumbarlo
luego la marca Castillo
esta mañana se evalúa lo que debe ser
cortado y lo que debe permanecer en pie
por el bien del Bosque
la albura parte conductora de la savia
ha sido degradada y se ve el aserrín
causado por los insectos luego el
trabajo de las aves y los pájaros
carpinteros que trataron de comerse
dichos insectos y pues es un árbol donde
se ve que ya no hay una sola rama con
vida estos árboles servirán de soporte
para muchas especies que nos interesan
ecológicamente
en cuanto a los árboles tumbados los
leños así se les llama serán
clasificados según su tamaño y su
destino 65 el 20% terminará como madera
de construcción y posiblemente en su
sala Aquí hay una segunda extensión
donde no hay nudos es decir que no hay
inserción de ramas en el árbol y ello
terminará haciendo un lindo parque
porque la gente Busca parques y nudos es
más bonito más estético encontramos
pequeñas y que no generan un gran
defecto en la madera
puede ser una pequeña mancha más bien
apetecida
estos roles centenarios están destinados
a la tolería
es una madera a la que se le da volumen
es redonda cilíndrica se ve muy bien es
muy importante para el comprador siempre
hay una sensación frente a la madera es
lo que busca un fabricante de barriles
es lo que busca un poco más lejos en una
parcela privada del Bosque fontaine Blue
Alain Busca más bien Con qué calentarse
de 10 árboles comercializados 8 terminan
en nuestras chimeneas entonces este
particular se aprovisiona directamente
en la Fuente a cambio de un acuerdo
financiero con el propietario aquí hay
arañazos en los árboles marca Esto está
este el que está allá El pequeño de aquí
casi todo el bosque está aquí a los
pequeños se les hará engordar los gordos
no son vendibles En todo caso a los
profesionales los venden a los
particulares la práctica no ha sido
difundida porque Hay que esforzarse
cortar cargar transportar su madera pero
ello cuesta tres veces menos que el
precio del mercado
con la elevación de los precios de la
energía a la madera para la calefacción
vuelve a ser elegida leños granulados
pero también virutas
hace poco esto no valía nada ahora en
este centro de compostaje de isla de
Francia se destroza todo lo que se pueda
desde el tuya más pequeño Hasta El
coloso Centenario tenemos plátano
resinoso frondoso miles de toneladas de
desechos verdes recuperados y
transformados con los que los
particulares las colectividades y las
empresas no sabían Qué hacer
antes este tipo de madera era o dejar a
un lado o quemada
actualmente se valoriza más y por lo
menos hay una valorización energética
peces de secado y usted obtiene un
combustible barato cuyas ventas
crecieron 70% estos 10 últimos años la
demanda de madera explota y a veces la
naturaleza Es la que se ve afectada en
la cadena de fui cerca de Clark ferran
Anthony guardabosques constata los daños
de la explotación intensiva hay una
máquina que pasa por aquí que busca
árboles ambos costados Con un brazo para
cortarlos y luego una segunda máquina
recuperar los pedazos cortados
quedan como espinas de pescado cuando se
observa desde las cimas
a unos cuantos kilómetros de aquí otro
método de explotación más artesanal y de
regreso el arrastre de la madera a
caballo una solución más laboriosa pero
todo terreno e corresponsable y muy
eficaz
Hola terminamos esta noche deberíamos
estar en 25 con los cuatro caballos 30
con los caballos todo es maniobrable
Buscamos un árbol a la derecha otro a la
izquierda y regresamos zixagueando entre
los árboles
Eso es conservado para el futuro
mientras que con la máquina un poco
menos
explotado pero rigurosamente vigilado el
bosque francés está en continua
expansión
cada año crece 85.000 hectáreas es decir
tres bosques de fountain Blue al año
[Música]